[موسيقى]
كل ام في
العالم تتحمل كل الالام والسهر اللي يتمر
بهشهر وتتحمل
عنط لكونها في النهايه حتحصل على هديه
ينضاف الى العائله وهو طفلها الجديد
وانا ايضا كام كنت
انتظر اللي هي الرابعه
هبه بصراحه جتي هبه كانت كلش لطيفه
وجميله ولكن كانت هادئه كلش هدوء اثار
انتباهي وخلاني اقلق قد يكون اكو هناك شي
خطا فقررت ان اخذها الى
الدكتور حتى اكسر الشك
باليقين ورحت الى الدكتور ومع
الاسف كانت الكارثه بلقائي
للطبيب لانه الطبيب عاملني بصوره غير
انسانيه بلغني انه هبه لا
تتكلم لا تقعد لا تمشي لا تتعلم لا تتزوج
وقاللي هي منغوليه بص الكلمه هذه ما كانت
لها معنى بالنسبه الي ما كنت اعرف عظمه
هذه الكلمه اللي قاللي اياها اباوع لبنتي
واقول معقوله ها الطفله الوديعه الجميله
تتحمل كل هاي اللاءات اللي قاللي اياها
الطبيب فكنت اتوقع انه اكو فشي خطا بهذا
الدكتور في ذلك اليوم مو الخطا ببنتي لان
مو معقوله كل اللي قاللي اياه هو في هذه
الطفله فاخذت بنتي وطلعت في اليوم الاخر
والورا رحت الى عده اطباء مع الاسف كان
نفس اللقاء ونفس
الحوار الكارثه هذه او الصدمه حطمت كل
احلامي
ببنتي
ولكن حاولت ان ادوس على قلبي وافتح باب
عقلي لان اذا اظل استسلم لوجودها بهاي
الطريقه معناها خسرت طفلتي
الرابعه نعم هي ما كانت مثل اخوانها اللي
قبلها ولكن مم ممكن ان اسوي فشي لان اني
ام ومن خلال خبرتي ذول الاولاد الثلاثه
ممكن ان استفيد من خبرتي وافيد هاي الطفله
وبالفعل تركت عملي كمدير للثانويه
وتحملت كل اللي شفته من اقرب الناس الي
لان مع الاسف احنا مجتمعنا قاسي لا يرحم
وهاي انا
اقولها من اقرب الناس الك تسمع الكلام
اللي جرح
فسديو على نفسي وعلى بنتي وبديت ادربها
كام بقلبي وبعقلي والحمد لله قدرت اغير
فالشيء كلش بسيط
بها سبحانه وتعالى الظاهر كان يخطط ويرسم
لي خط حياتي طلعت دراسه زوجي الى الخارج
وطلعنا كعائله ويانا هبه عمرها 11
شهر ل يعني رحنا احنا الى انجلترا وما
كانت عندي مشكله باللغه لان انا اختصاص
لغه انجليزيه وبديت هناك اسال وحتى من
اشوف الناس بالشارع اروح عليهم اسالهم على
مود انه هم يشبهون بنتي بس اريد اتعلم
وبالفعل ما خليت كتاب ما قراته مكاتبهم
دخلتها مؤتمراتهم حضرتها صرت عضو في
الجمعيه اللي هي خاصه بالداون سندروم
وتعلمت ف حقيقه المفروض هسه اني ابلغها ل
واحد وفعلا كل من يجيني للمركز اقوله يا
هذول ما يختلفون
عننا هذول كل انسان طبيعي خلقه الله او
غير طبيعي هو عباره عن خلايا بها
كروموسومات كل انسان عنده 46 كروموسوم في
كل خليه اكو 46 كروموسوم يعني 23 زوج
سبحانه وتعالى فقط الخليه التناسليه
يخلقها من 2 فرد لدى المراه و 2 فرد لدى
الزوج فلما تنتقي البويضه المخصبه يصير
عندها 3 زوج اللي هي من هاي الكروموسومات
وها الكروموسومات هي عباره عن حامله لكل
الجينات اللي تاخذها من الام ومن
الاب بعدين من خلال معرفتي هنا عرفت انه
هاي
الخلايا بالنسبه للشخص النورمال هو عباره
عن فقط عند ا يسي 21 بينما بالداون سندروم
اللي هو الاسم العلمي لهؤلاء الاطفال
الاسم العلمي هو داون سندروم داون اسم
الطبيب اللي اكتشف الحاله وسندر الصفات
اللي تطلع مع
الطفل فعرفت انه الفرق بين الطفل الطبيعي
والطفل اللي داون سندروم هو مجرد خليه في
ترايسي 2 وهو بثلا وذا
يسموه 21 تراسي هو
95% من حالات الداون سندروم وهذا النوع هو
مو وراثي نهائيا 95% من هؤلاء الاطفال مو
وراثه لا سبب الام ولا سبب الاب وانما هو
سبب خطا في الانشطار وهذا سبحانه وتعالى
هو اللي يختار العائله وينط ايهم اياه اكو
نوعين اخرين ايضا تعلمت من عندهم انه
النوع اللي على اليسار هو يسموه المتنقل
جزء من الكروموسوم يتنقل الى كروموسوم 14
او 15 وهذا به نسبه قليله جدا من الوراثه
من ثلاثه الى خمسه وعرفت ايضا انه اكو نوع
ثالث يسموه الموزايك وهذا الموزايك هو
عباره عن نصف خلايا او ربع خلايا او تبدي
بالانشطار الحقيقي اللي هو 46 وبعدين على
غفله يصير الخطا بالانشطار فيظل الطفل
متحص عنده في جسمه قسم من الخلايا
الطبيعيه وقسم من الخلايا اللي بها 47
كروموسوم هذا ايضا بنسبه ق من الوراثه من
ثلاثه الى خمسه فكل هاي الاشياء انا
بصراحه تعلمتها تعلمت اسمه تعلمت ليش هو
صار تعلمت نوعه تعلمت صفاته هذا الطفل ما
يفرق عنه انا بنتي كانت من ولادته في
العراق كانت هاي الطفله يسموها معاقه في
حين لما رحت الى مجتمع اخر وهو يعني نفس
الطفله ما راح تغير بها شي وانما ما كانوا
يسموها معاقه اذا هو ليس الطفل هو المعاق
وانما هو المجتمع وانا ااكد وتاكد من كلام
ليسان انه هو فعلا هو المجتمع هو اللي
يخلي الطفل ان يكون
[تصفيق]
معاق تريدون تسالوني تقولوا لي شو تغير
بهبه ورا ما رجعتي ورا ست عفو ست سنوات من
دراسه رجعنا هبه عمرها ست سنين هبه تقرا
تكتب تمشي تحكي وواصله الى 3
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
و
شكرا خل
نكمل شكرا جزيلا ورجعت الى القطر ولكن
رجعت شخص اخر وانسان اخر واهداف اخرى
ومبادئ اخرى كنت انا من رايحه الى لندن
كان عندي بنيه واحده بس من رجعت للبلد كان
عندي في دماغي هوايه اهداف ردت احول كل
هؤلاء الاطفال اللي يعتبرهم معاقين الى
اشخاص تقريبا طبيعيين اكو نقص عندهم صحيح
بس هاي يسموها حاجه خاصه ممكن ان احنا
نقدم لهم الخدمه اللي تقدر تغير من هاي
الحاجه
الخاصه وكيف ابدي هذا الشي اول شي بديت
بعمل سنتر في بيتي مركز لتعليم حمله اعراض
داون وكان بها اربع اطفال اول مره وبعدين
وصلوا الى عدد 150
طالب
بعدين اناي شفت في نفسي انه مو فقط ممكن
ان اغير الطفل لا لازم اكو عده خطوات حتى
يعيشون بسلام والخطوه الاولى اللي هي
والاب والاخوان هذول الخطوه الاولى لان
المحيط اللي يدير هذا الطفل اذا ما يتغير
بافكاره ومبادئ ما راح يقدر الطفل يستفيد
فاول ما تجيني الام الى السنتر احاول ان
انسى انه هي عندها دام احاول ان اتناول
الام والاب واطلعهم من عزلتهم ومن خوفهم
ومن خجلهم حتى يكونون اشخاص اقوياء ينطون
القوه لهؤلاء لان اذا هم ضعفاء كيف راح
يقوون اولادهم فالام اول شي اغيرها اشوفها
اقتنعت انه ابنها ممكن ان يصير بعدين يلا
انتقل الى الطفل حسيت ايضا انه مو كافي
انه فقط عائله اللي عندها داون لازم اثقف
اذا شلون انا شخص واحد طبعا ومساعده زوجي
واولادي ما انكر فضلهم
ابدا فقدمت على الجمعيه العراقيه لرعايه
حمده عرا الدام من سنه 96 صدقوني لل 99
وبقدره يلا حصلت الموافقه اربع سنوات اني
احارب يوميه رايحه وجايه ما يقبلون ينطوني
جمعيه بعدين سوينا الجمعيه العراقيه
لرعايه حم دام والتزمت كل العوائل في داخل
الجمعيه وبديت اطور العوائل وما يحيط بهم
حتى خليتهم اعمامهم خالاتهم كلهم يجون
ينتمون للجمعيه لان هذا الطفل حيكون في
بيئه مو فد بيت واحد داير مدايره
كلهم بعدين شفت
انه الطبيب الطبيب اللي انا اول شي ما
صدمني لازم ابدا ادخل عليه واغير بهذا
الطبيب لازم اغير را فكان كل ما تصير
مؤتمر او محاضره في بغداد اني اروح اخذ
ركن واعرف كل مواهب اولادي اولادي ممكن ان
مثلا علي عندكم يقرا ويكتب انجليزي عربي
وواصل وبنفس الوقت هم اثنيناتهم عندي
يدرسون طلاب التدخل المبكر هم عمرهم سن
[تصفيق]
فاذا هم قابلين للتعلم والتاهيل وممكن ان
يلزمون وظائف حتى لو ابسط ما يكون علمناهم
على الرياضيات ممكن ان يفتحون محل وعندي
فارس طبعا اني ما خليت هذه بصراحه التهيت
بيه فما قلبت هذا علاوي ده يدرس الطلاب
اللي اصغر منه ايضا داون سندروم في السنتر
ادنا المواهب الفنيه ممكن ان يكونون
ويمامه شاركت في لبنان وفازوا شاركت في
اليونان وفازوا هاي المداليه
مالتهم يقدر يقول لي واحد يسالني زين
يتزوجون ذو نعم من حقهم من حقهم هم بشر من
حقهم ان يتزوجون فلا تمنعوهم المجتمع لا
يكون قاسي على هال الاطفال في سبيل ان ما
ينطيهم حقوقهم كل حقوقهم كامله يجب ان
ياخذوها بهذا المجتمع يجب ان وعدي طفل
متزوج هو وعائلته وزوجته وعايش
بسعاده هاي بنتي وانا فقدتها طبعا سنه
2007 بس صدقوني انا ولدي اطباء ومهندسين
قبلها ما علموني اللي علمتني ا هبه هبه
علمتني ان اكون صبوره علمتني ان اتفد في
خدمه الاخرين علمتني ان انكر ذاتي واسهر
واشتغل على مودهم واقرا استمر اطور بنفسي
في سبيل تطويرهم اذا هي احسن من الطبيب
واحسن المهندس واحسن من الدكتور شكرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جزيلا
ه